[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، لقد رأيت فريقًا يلعب
في قمة لعبته تمامًا
في الوقت الحالي وفريقًا واحدًا
يكافح من أجل المستوى في الوقت الحالي
يكونون فيه غير منظمين تمامًا
عندما تكون غير منظم ضد فريق
مثل  ليفربول بعد ذلك
سوف يعاقبونك ولديهم الكثير من
اللاعبين يلعبون بشكل جيد في الوقت الحالي ، مو
صلاح بالطبع هو واحد منهم وقد
عاقبهم
أي ثغرات صغيرة في
درعك في الوقت الحالي.  سوف
يؤذيك ومانشستر يونايتد ليس في داخلك كما
تعلمون في حالة جيدة في الوقت الحالي
لديهم بعض اللاعبين الرائعين أعتقد أن
مانشستر يونايتد هو فريق
يتحسن ويتحسن من حيث
لاعبيه لكنهم ليسوا كذلك  يلعب
بشكل جيد كفريق في الوقت الحالي
[موسيقى]
إنه لاعب مذهل إنه جيد جدًا
لدرجة أنه يلعب في ليفربول في
الوقت الحالي لأنه
في رأيي في مستواه الحالي هو
اللاعب الأكثر فتكًا في
العالم  أفضل لاعب في العالم أ  نحن
نقف
في شكل جيد ،
أعني أن الأهداف التي يسجلها هي فقط
كل أسبوع يسجله
ويسجله ويسجله ،
وهو نعم يستحق ذلك ، إنه يبذل الكثير من الجهد
في
أنه يتمتع بسلوك رائع إنه متفاني للغاية
ومن ثم لديه بعض الصفات الرائعة.
أعلم أنه سريع ،
إنه قوي ، لقد حسّن نهايته
على مر السنين ،
لذا نعم أنا سعيد
تمامًا لأنه يلعب بشكل جيد ، وإذا
استمر في فعل ذلك
لمدة موسمين آخرين ، فسيكون
لديه الكثير من السجلات وآمل أن
تكون كذلك  أعرف أنه يقع على الأبواب والمزيد من الجوائز
لمجموعته
[موسيقى] ،
أعتقد أنه لا يزال يتعين عليه أن يذهب
قليلاً إلى أه ليصبح أفضل لاعب ، نعم ،
أعني أن ستيفن جيرارد بالطبع
ربما يكون أحد أفضل اللاعبين في كل
العصور إيان  اندفاع أعتقد
أنه يجب أن يكون قد سجل ثلاثة أضعاف
أهداف ليفربول أكثر من مو صلاح ، لذلك
إذا استمر في السير على هذا النحو ،
فأنا متأكد من أننا سنتحدث
عن أحد أعظم أهداف ليفربول على الإطلاق
وهو أه  وهو
إنجاز مذهل ولكن يجب أن
يستمر في فعل ذلك للوصول
إلى هذا المستوى بالطبع ، لكنه يؤدي بشكل
جيد
للغاية حتى الآن
قال
قبل أن أعتقد أن مانشستر يونايتد يتحد
الفريق ، فأنت تعلم أن التوقيع على
أمثال إيران ورونالدو
سيحسن فريقك بشكل طبيعي
لكنهم ما زالوا بحاجة إلى التحسين
من حيث اللعب كفريق
وليس أفرادًا ضد ليفربول ، كان من
الصعب جدًا  شاهد ما إذا كنت من
مشجعي مانشستر يونايتد وتفتقر إلى
التنظيم
ومرة أخرى إذا لعبت ضد لي
ربول وإذا لم تكن من
مًا جيدًا فسوف يقتلكون ، لذا آه
عم إن
لا يزال بحاجة إلى مزيد من الوقت على ما أع
قد  لا تحب حقًا رؤية
الأشخاص الذين يقومون بإقالة المدير طوال الوقت أو عدم الدفاع عنها بالتأكيد ،
لكننا نعلم جميعًا أنه إذا
لم يتحسن ، فسيكون من
الصعب عليك أن تعلم أن القرار صعب
على المدير.  لوب ، لذلك أعتقد أنه سيحصل على الوقت
ولكنه بحاجة إلى التحسين والتحسين
بسرعة كبيرة
[موسيقى]